[Music]
one pair of ray-bans made in partnership
with facebook
two basically hidden cameras
so many people who don't know you're
recording them
would you have known i was recording you
with these sunglasses
yeah because these sunglasses have a
camera in it
this is a terrible idea
did you know i was recording you no i
had no idea i would not have known
because it says raven now before you
start calling me a total creeper let's
talk about these shades and why i've
been recording random people these are
not your old tom cruise ray-ban wayfarer
glasses although some might say they're
risky business
these are ray-ban stories a 299 dollar
pair of high-tech glasses made with
facebook tap here and this 5 megapixel
camera records video of whatever you're
looking at
this small led light is supposed to
signal to people you're recording the
idea of camera equipped glasses
definitely not new
there was google glass which
didn't go so well
they don't work anymore and more
recently snapchat spectacles similar to
those these are meant to let you put
down your smartphone and record without
looking at a screen
but here is what's new super cool
classic looking sunglasses with high
quality cameras and microphones most
don't notice that tiny little recording
light and don't think twice when you're
wearing these glasses they basically
just think you look awesome
which could basically make these spy
glasses
so i devised my own little social
experiment this week talk to as many
people as i could and see if they knew i
was recording some thought they were
creepy
others thought they were cool supporting
you right now and yes i told people i
was recording quickly after hitting the
button and got everyone's permission to
use their footage in this video
let's start with the cool and how these
work tap once on this button and you
begin recording video
video was cut off after 30 seconds since
yes these were designed for facebook and
instagram stories
long press and you can snap a photo
that's where the second camera comes in
it gathers depth information so you can
apply these fun effects to photos
afterwards you can also say hey facebook
take a picture the quality isn't exactly
what you'd get with the latest iphone
but it's not bad for sharing
but why would you want any of this
well these are actually really fun and
useful in those situations where you
don't want to just take your phone out
plus the first person point of view is
just awesome
whoa
oh yeah facebook specifically says don't
drive with these on and yeah they're not
waterproof either
those photos and videos are stored to
four gigabytes of storage in the glasses
but they also sync with a new app called
facebook view
they don't automatically go to facebook
or instagram
in the view app you can download them to
your phone and easily share them to any
place you'd like
facebook says none of the photos in the
app are used for personalized ads only
if you share them do the app's terms
apply
there are also speakers in here so you
can listen to music or take calls when
paired with your phone what do you mean
you're calling from your glasses
you now have a phone in your glasses
well they're just regular sunglasses but
with cameras and microphones
now the coolness is almost the reason
they're so creepy no one expects when
you're wearing these that you've got two
cameras on your face
plus the led indicator is very small i'm
talking somewhere between the size of a
poppy seed and a sesame seed
[Music]
very dry
very very dry
unlike the big indicators on the
snapchat spectacles people just don't
notice it and outdoors the light is even
harder to see
what's impossible
to know that i'm recording you right now
can you see now
i can
facebook says this gesture of bringing
your hand up to your temple to record is
another signal to people that you're
recording
but lots of people didn't pick up on
that either
and when you set up your stories the
view app suggests that you do a demo for
people to let them know how the capture
led works
the company also says that the 30 second
recording limit is another privacy
measure to ensure people aren't being
recorded at length without their
knowledge
still they should have made this
indicator bigger and maybe red or green
i'm not saying they needed to put
something the size of this on there but
something that was at least noticeable
so what did i learn here from this
non-scientific social experiment years
ago it was hard to imagine smartphones
with cameras everywhere but we
eventually learned that this meant
someone was recording
now the miniaturization of technology
into sleek looking glasses is coming
these ray-bans are just the start
but with that we at the very least need
a bigger indicator that these aren't
just classic sunglasses but cameras
capable of recording
everyone we meet and yes nice lady i met
in the park
i do work for the fbi